true
this oil well elongate everywhere
that spectral aviation of all dry
the levels of everything that is that is
pollute the animals that eat
these die because this action the
oil all here the only thing to leave
pollution or death nothing is what
everything that is going to be left of here
indigo town
then the community decided that this
income that this income to one of the
places also this that the government has
intended to sell to communities
Mapuche cut them the community decided
keep this cut we have been 33 days
to get us out of this place we are going to
have to kill because we're not leaving
we are going to leave if the story is told
what to repeat will be repeated in this
community
in this way the conversion of money